[Music]
the white dots on the screen the
adrenaline started pumping and then bond
to turning towards the barrel and firing
when that comes on screens like settle
in and get ready for a ride for me as a
writer and a director it was essential
to rediscover bond where is he after
five years of retirement who has he
become he's sort of a wounded animal
struggling with his role as a double-o
the world's changed the rules of
engagement aren't what they used to be
the rules of espionage darker in this
era of asymmetric warfare the people
close to bond those he considers to be
family are at great risk and now there's
someone new out there more dangerous
than anyone has ever encountered and
whoever they are is smarter and stronger
inspector
[Music]
call to action to the end of the film as
a grace not only to save the world
but their lives no time to die is the
culmination of all that Bond has become
with all that he's seen all the trauma
the loss what is that mission that would
be his most challenging and most
difficult that was our target and we aim
to do something extraordinary with this
one
every Bond film has that thing the
danger but also the emotional punch
everything that was left unsaid will
finally be said
this will be the final chapter for
General Craig
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why whatever trait we all have our
secrets we just didn't get to yours yet
the world is arming faster than we can
respond
where's double-oh-seven I need a favor
brother you're the only one I trust for
this
the world's moved on commander bond you
would go below two years so stay in your
lane you get in my way I will put
together two new knee
that works
never what you two would get along named
Vonda
James Bond so you're not dead hello Q I
missed you
it's the most valuable asset this
country has if you feel yourself losing
control I'm not going to lose
control
James you gave up everything for her
when her secret finds its way out
they'll be the death of him what is it
you don't know what this is James Bond
license to kid history of violence I
could be speaking to my own reflection
only your skills die with her body mine
will survive long after I'm gone history
isn't kind to men who play God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]